Baltimore has a police problem here are
four WTF moments from the DOJ
investigation of the Baltimore PD there
really shouldn't surprise you one BPD is
hella racist the Department of Justice
found that police stopped black
residents three times more than white
residents and of the 410 people who were
stopped more than ten times ninety-five
percent were black supervisors have even
ordered officers to arrest all the black
hoodies in a neighborhood to BPD is
hella ineffective officers conducted
300,000 pedestrian stops in 65 months
but only three point seven percent
resulted in citation or arrest one black
man in his mid-50s was stopped 30 times
in less than a year and he was never
charged three BPD is hella violent
officers are accused of using aggressive
tactics with civilians which contributes
to systematic use of unreasonable force
the report also says police used
excessive force against a mentally ill
juveniles and people who are already
restrained oh yeah and nearly ninety
percent of force incidents involved
African Americans for BPD is hella
unaccountable in the period of review
Baltimore police recorded over 2800
incidents where force was used but only
ten were investigated that's not even
one percent so what can Baltimore do to
fix its police problem
you